Hi, we're here with Tomer Sharon, a
senior user researcher in Google search.
Thank you for joining us.
>> Thanks for having me.
>> So, what is user research?
>> User research is a discipline
that is providing insights,
keyword insights, into product users,
their perspectives and
abilities to the right
people at the right time.
So that's the official definition.
To make it more understandable,
user research is there to help
answer three big questions.
The first one is what do people need?
The second is what do people want?
Which is different than what they need.
And the third one is can they use
the thing that we're working on?
Whatever the thing is.
>> Is user research only for new ideas?
>> No.
Otherwise, I wouldn't have a job.
You start, you have a new idea,
you validate or invalidate it.
There are tons of decisions
an entrepreneur is making about their
product every day.
I'm not saying all of them should
be covered by user research, but
it's not just for new ideas.
If you have, if you want to develop,
we all do, we have new ideas for
new features and
how to improve the product.
Some of them may involve,
again, a lot of work.
So for those things that may involve
a lot of work, I would try and
find out if they're worth it.
Again, is it a problem worth solving?
>> Or a feature?
>> Or a feature.
Yes.
Definitely.
>> So, how do I move from
user research to decisions?
>> So, in order for
you to make decisions,
you first need to know what about?
And that leads me to how do we
start the process of users.
The first thing you need to do is
make it very clear for yourself, and
for your team, what is the question
that we're trying to answer.
So after you did your research,
if we want to move to making decisions,
you first need answers
to those questions.
>> Right.
>> That you started with.
What happens in many
cases is that you have
answers to questions
that you didn't ask.
You didn't know how to ask, or
you weren't even aware
that they were questions.
That's fine.
But if you want to start with research,
the first thing you
need to do is make a list of
the questions you're trying to answer.
What are the questions that we will have
answers to by the end of this research?
This research effort will fail if we
don't have answers to these questions.
>> So
I write a list of all the assumptions?
>> Yes, yes.
Assumptions is a perfect
way to describe it.
An assumption can easily be
translated into a question.
And it doesn't have to be long.
Sometimes one, two, three questions,
it's perfectly fine, okay?
So as soon as you are done with
research, you should have answers.
Those answers can help
you make decisions.
I always start when my team and
I are trying to start a research effort.
I always try to identify
where is this coming from?
Why are we talking now?
And I'm doing that because I'm trying
to understand what is the question that
we're trying to answer.
So I'm looking for
dilemmas that people or teams have.
Arguments that they have.
I attend a lot of meetings and
I just watch.
Sometimes we have data
that we can't explain.
Why is this happening?
And things like that.
So, this can be translated
into questions and
then answers, and these answers
would lead us to making decisions.